voeux de de la compétition a remis 2020
dont 4 équipes des lots russie
azerbaïdjan russie et chine
les chars seront en bleu pour la
biélorussie jaune pour l'azerbaïdjan
rouge pour la russie et vert pour la
chine donc vous voyez ici devant ce char
vers l'équipage de compétition de la
chine
voyez le commandant le pilote et le
tireur vous voyez des représentants de
l'équipe de compétition de la chimie
devant ce châle rouge
l'équipe de la fédération de russie
le commandant de chat le tireur pointer
et le mécanicien pilote cet équipage
représente la fédération de russie
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant un char jaune l'équipage
qui représente l'équipe des abats de
jean le cam au de chars le tireur
pointer et le mécanicien pilotes
il représente l'équipe d'hazard baddou
et enfin devant ce char pas en bleu
l'équipe
l'équipage de biélorussie le commandant
de chars le tireur pointer et le
mécanicien pilote donc chers amis voici
donc la finale qui va commencer
c'est évidemment l'étape qui clôt toute
cette compétition et qui va être
particulièrement intéressante
aujourd'hui donc devant vous sur le
terrain d'entraînement dallas bino le
début des épreuves donc le signal
d'appel a retenti et les équipages
s'installe à l'intérieur de leur char
prêt à partir sur la ligne de départ
donc de gauche à droite envers la chine
en rouge la russie en jaune
l'azerbaïdjan en bleu la biélorussie
donc là ils vont partie elles vont
quitter la ligne de départ en même temps
chaque équipage doit parcourir quatre
tours sur le parcours d'épreuves à
l'intérieur des chars nos équipages sont
prêts à les vivre que la russie soit
vainqueur le général van joukov vous
donne les dernières instructions avant
de donner le départ pour ce biathlon des
chars
et oui l'équipe de kazakhstan n'a pas
réussi à se qualifier en finale et le
raf
ils ont manqué il aura manqué cinq
secondes pour être sélectionné en finale
donc cette année on voit une présence
tout à fait renouveler pour cette finale
donc depuis quelques années on voit
l'équipe de biélorussie qui est fait et
voilà c'est parti pour cette édition la
finale de cette édition 2020 donc
passage sur un pont
donc vous voyez le chat deux airbags
gens en tête pour ce premier tour donc
il va y avoir un tir sur des cibles
imitant des chars d'assaut est vrai que
notamment une épreuve de tir sur le côté
et qui est particulièrement intéressante
donc l'équipe de l'azerbaïdjan va tirer
au canon antiaérien
en cas d'infraction aux règles l'équipe
l'équipage qui a commis une erreur doit
se revenir sur la plateforme de pénalité
si la cible n'est pas atteinte lors des
tirs dans ce cas précis les règles ont
changé cette année il y a notamment des
épreuves de tir en marche
là vous voyez un et qu'il un obstacle
[Applaudissements]
donc en cas de tir manqué à ce moment là
l'équipage peut bénéficier de d'obus de
réserve
[Applaudissements]
alors sur le point escarpé vous voyez
passer ici les différents chars et là on
voit ce magnifique char rouge qui
représente la russie qui est en tête
[Musique]
là ils vont commencer le tir de côté
donc ça c'est l'épreuve de tir la plus
intéressante donc notre équipage qui est
issu du district du sud
là on voit les chinois qui commencent
l'épreuve
donc ils ont trois cibles représentés
et voilà notre équipage russe est en
train de d'installer les munitions
nécessaires pour l'épreuve de tir donc
ce sont des obus de 16km de 16 kg donc
[Musique]
voilà les les chinois ont déjà réussi à
toucher une première cible donc entre 7
aux environs de 700 mètres de distance
encore une cible atteinte et en même
temps l'azerbaïdjan a réussi à toucher
une de ses cibles
[Musique]
donc bravo à l'équipage chinois qui part
et maintenant on voit les meilleurs le
meilleur équipage de chardes azerbaïdjan
qui est ici et là on a une cible qui
représente un hélicoptère
voilà l'azerbaïdjan a touché sa cible
ils peuvent continuer attention
l'équipage russe tir de côté notre
équipage se prépare c'est le sergent
salade score avec la disco qui se
prépare aux tirs
[Musique]
donc l'épreuve de tir sur le côté en
mouvement à 3,4 km heure de mouvement
attention
voilà il a frappé la cible bravo c'est
un très bon début mais il ya encore
d'autres tirs à faire ici 1700 mètres de
distance
on a le coeur serré on regarde tous les
partisans autour regarde
bravo des à table et des
applaudissements sincères et chaleureux
[Applaudissements]
et voilà le sergent paul la disco 1900
mètres maintenant
et voilà
la cible est à che bravo la russie
allait on continue le mouvement 100
tours de pénalité
voilà c'est le sergent palace koné en
1996 on est fier de lui bravo séparant
sont ici bravo félicitations aux parents
pour cet excellent militaire et là on
voit le char de l'équipe de biélorussie
ils ont fait un premier tour sans
effectuer de tir
donc il n'a pas eu de tirs à effectuer
non que si on voit le char franchir un
obstacle aquatique
revenons nous reviendrons un peu plus
tard sur notre équipage est là on voit
le chat chinois qui a un peu de retard
et voilà regardez-le excellent tir d'un
autre tireur pointer russe et là vous
voyez c'est très bien mais aujourd'hui
les tribunes sont pleines les gens ne
retiennent pas leur émotion c'est un
spectacle magnifique que vous pouvez
voir ici qui se poursuit la ici vous
voyez donc ce sont des chars t-90 mvb m
pardon est traditionnellement les
chinois sont sur leur char à eux
ce sont des chars t-72 transforme en
voilà avec ses roches hancock et le
principal entraîneur de notre équipage
et vous voyez la foule qui salue
l'équipage russe après son premier tour
donc l'azerbaïdjan pour l'instant vais
simplement effectué un tour de vitesse
donc ils ont un pit stop là pour
l'instant deux qui sont obligés de
descendre et effectuer une bref un bref
tour d'horizon tour de l'équipement
l'azerbaïdjan doit faire une une sortie
du véhicule pour avoir commis une
infraction a lors d'un passage des
preuves
et là vous voyez maintenant un tir de
côté encore une fois voilà
l'équipage de l'azerbaïdjan pour
repartir donc voyez que c'était on a eu
une demi finale assez difficile entre le
kazakhstan et l'azerbaïdjan j'étais
quasiment nez à nez mais l'azerbaïdjan
réussi à se qualifier pour cette finale
donc bravo et l'équipe de kazakhstan on
a perdu face aux à l'azerbaïdjan que sur
cinq secondes
donc on est à 2 9 minutes 56 pour
l'achèvement du premier tour tous les
équipages ont déjà en train sont déjà en
train de franchir leur deuxième tour et
là c'est un tour qui constituons une
épreuve de vitesse
vous voyez l'équipage de russie qui va
maintenant faire un tir au canon
antiaérien notre équipe s'arrête il faut
éteindre la machine descendre et ensuite
revenir dedans
donc franchissement de
l'obstacle à quoi tu y es que pour
l'équipe
l'équipage de chine
et c'est maintenant le sage ambitieuse
qui va tirer au canon antiaérien
maintenant on va regarder la séance de
tir de l'équipage de bien réussi une
première cible qui représente un
hélicoptère
[Applaudissements]
bravo biélorusse
[Musique]
et bravo notre notre équipage russe a
touché des cibles alors du tir au canon
antiaérien bravo à lui et on voit en
même temps l'équipage de biélorussie qui
poursuit sa séance de tir à distance
donc nous souhaitons évidemment toutes
les équipes de d'être brillante donc
troisième cible pour la biélorussie
distance 1900 m
voilà bravo
pas de tour de pénalité pour les
biélorusses il continue
[Musique]
on voit les équipages qui sont sur les
tribunes et qui doivent ensuite prendre
place dans les chats grâce aux
équipements gps installés dans les dents
les charmes maintenant les équipages ont
la possibilité d'améliorer leur conduite
et leur mouvement voilà garder et voilà
encore trois cibles atteintes c'est la
répétition de ce qu'on a vu il ya cinq
minutes et voilà là aussi l'équipe le
chant russe qui se dépêchent et séances
de tir donc pour l'azerbaïdjan
donc la cible 9 2-9 qui représente des
chars donc c'est un tir antichar ici
donc tirent sûr mais travailleuse
jumelées ici avec des balles traçantes
pour chaque équipage ya toujours sur la
tour de jury a toujours le l'entraîneur
de chaque iep équipage qui est présent
pour suivre l'évolution dès le passage
des épreuves
et encore un objectif bravo
l'azerbaïdjan
[Musique]
donc
à un moment de tension on attend on
regarde et bravo ils ont réussi les
trois cibles ont été atteintes
bravo très bonne préparation très bonne
formation
donc on voit que tous les équipages
c'est la même chose on constate c'est
une très nette amélioration de la
formation et de l'instruction l'année
dernière on a vu des équipages qui avait
été disqualifié mais ici ce n'est pas le
cas cette année
[Musique]
landes années le vietnam avait remporté
cette épreuve
voilà la russie 15 minutes 28 secondes
donc on a encore des tours de réserve
pour pouvoir rattraper les quelques
secondes de perdues et la chine a déjà
passé l'épreuve de vitesse
et nous avons encore donc un tour de
vitesse qui nous permettrait de
rattraper le temps perdu
grâce à ce schéma infographique vous
pouvez voir où on en est vous voyez la
vitesse des différents chars donc
l'équipage du char chinois est arrivé
sur le point de chargement des munitions
donc les missions principales sont
chargés et le char se prépare à
effectuer son tir sur les cibles et on
va voir
donc à chaque char sont disposés des
cibles de la même couleur donc ici
premier premier tir à 1600 mètres
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
attendez vous encore regardé ce tir
après d'un autre point de vue l on va
voir sur le deuxième la deuxième cible
voilà on a pu revoir
et voilà deuxième tir
et on a appris qu entre temps la
biélorussie a commis à des pénalités
pour infraction au franchissement d'un
des obstacles ils vont devoir faire un
pit stop avec une inspection du véhicule
et donc après le tir à 1800 mètres
maintenant là il suit volontiers sur
1900 mètres
voilà les trois cibles ont été les
supporters de l'équipe de cet équipage
chinois manifestent leur enthousiasme
donc ce tte 96b chinois avec un canon de
125 mm qui est assez similaire un autre
t 72 russe donc la russie au troisième
tour pour l'instant maintenant c'est la
3e épreuve de tir en bas sur l'écran
vous voyez la biélorussie en train
d'effectuer ses tirs sur contre
hélicoptères et véhicules
et bravo les cibles sans fin
et voilà on continue regarde donc la
russie continue à dire bravo voilà ici
ça 700 m et voilà à brefs tirs à la
mitrailleuse bravement encore une fois
notre charge ans se battre a très bien
tiré bravo il nous reste encore un tour
à faire qui est un tour de vitesse sans
épreuve particulière de tirs a effectué
pendant ce tour
vous voyez le commandant de chat
[Musique]
vos bonnes vitesses
69 70 km heure
[Musique]
l'année dernière
la vitesse de 84 km rv été atteintes
lors de la finale l'an dernier ce qui
avait été un record absolu sur chars
[Musique]
donc
regardez comment les les équipages sont
concentrés ici sur la mission inventaire
ils m'ont toutes les capacités de leur
armement et là l'équipage russe est
particulièrement concentrée là vous
voyez le char de
biélorussie
[Musique]
voilà l'équipe l'équipage de russie aura
encore un tour faire donc il franchit là
le l'obstacle aquatique
elle est tout le monde est concentré sur
la victoire ici ce n'est pas seulement
notre équipe a nommé tout on va partir
et des mairies des autres équipes
[Musique]
pendant qu'il ya le premier équipage de
biélorussie qui effectue cette épreuve
c'est ainsi 72 b3 regardez regardez sur
ce replay comment cette étape a été
franchie donc un passage étroit ici
et là les preuves de la colline de la
butte donc
c'est une butte de six mètres de haut
qui en fait ne représente pas de
difficulté particulière pour nos chars
vous avez vu le char glisser ici dérapé
dans le virage
et la russie
à cherves son dernier tour avec épreuves
de tir et la maintenance c'est le tour
de vitesse pure
on continue aujourd'hui
donc évidemment les équipages
n'entendent pas nos applaudissements
mais nous les soutenons tous ceux qui
nous regardent et si en direct et tous
ceux qui sont présents ici sur les
tribunes salon les applaudissons ils ont
besoin de notre soutien
et il ya nos charmantes jeunes filles
russes ceux qui les soutiennent
et voilà le char chinois se prépare à
effectuer son tir au canon antiaérien
sur leur t 96b voilà la cible se lève et
ils l'ont déjà frappé c'est la cible de
numéro 25
il mettant un hélicoptère en vol
stationnaire et un véhicule le armés
donc distance ici de 900 m là aussi elle
en est à son quatrième tour la
biélorussie à son troisième les
armatures gociations 3ème et la chine
effectue son quatrième tour
on continue son tour de pénalité donc là
ça devient sérieux parce que la russie 2
à son quatrième tour la chine aussi donc
virage pour reprendre l'itinéraire
voilà la chine et la russie vous voyez
un duel en direct ici lé pour les
premiers équipages de compétition
aujourd'hui ils sont au coude à coude
relief le pilote de char on lui demande
d'aller le plus vite possible d'appuyer
sur la [ __ ]
regardez regardez regardez on est dans
un mouchoir de poche
regardez-la la vitesse a été de 78 km
heure c'est presque 80 80 km heure
[Musique]
attention il ya ensuite un virage très
difficile ils sont au coude à coude
[Musique]
notre mécanicien pilote va df est en
tête l'un attention aux virages en
profondeur et ensuite il ya le passage
de relais et donc il va falloir ensuite
pas quoi une distance de 100 mètres pour
le passage de relais
regardez et sans s'arrêter continue
et regardez cette course est
impressionnant
et là faut sortir le plus vite possible
de cet obstacle pour ne pas perdre de
temps
la distance à peu près de 35 40 mètres
entre les deux les nerfs sont en tension
maximale
[Musique]
regardez très bons sauts ici sur le
tremplin à l'issue de la butte
on ralentit en sortie d'obstacles et là
en ligne directe et il ne reste pas
grand chose avec le passage du fossé
passage étroit ici attention
l'équipage de biélorussie a procédé à
son sa réalimentation en armement
quatrième tour pour la biélorussie tire
aucun enterrement
regardez regardez on arrive au passage
de relais c'est très très juste
et là on voit l'équipage
qui passe de bill a aussi qui possède au
tir et voilà les deux chars chinois et
russes s'arrêtent en même temps qu'elle
le dit qu'elle lutte et l'art et
maintenant il faut courir 100 mètres
pour passer le relais
[Applaudissements]
et on voit le passage de relais au
deuxième équipage d'un contact de la
main et on a le sergent bowles cas les
offres
voilà quasiment en même temps les deux
équipages montre les chinois vont était
un peu plus rapide aller en avant la
russie de l'avant en attendant la
biélorussie l'équipage de biélorussie a
touché les trois cibles du stand numéro
[Musique]
allez il faut tenir il faut pas baisser
les bras et il ya encore deux équipages
ensuite qu'ils devront intervenir aussi
vous voyez ici le ministre de la défense
à droite
sergueï choïgou héros de russie
il est venu soutenir notre équipe
regardez ce passage qui était vraiment
impressionnant et là l'équipage de
l'azerbaïdjan qui charge son char pour
procéder aux épreuves de tir
allez on est tous unis autour de nos
équipes
[Musique]
regardez le charrue se prend les devants
ils savent être le pour ce premier tour
il faut procéder au tir de côté on voit
ces très jolies supportrices ont
applaudi seydoux allez-y
l'équipage d'azerbaïjan s'apprête à
effectuer ces tirs les trois cibles
numéro 19
le tireur a déjà participé à plusieurs
compétitions de chat
[Musique]
regardez on espère va espérer qu'ils
vont pas perdre de temps au moment de
dire voilà le tueur pointer procède au
ciblage
pour l'instant les trois autres
équipages ont déjà effectués ont déjà
touché toutes les cibles
on a eu cette année exceptionnelle qui
est passée les tous les équipages de
chars se sont entraînés ont suivi leur
formation ils ont bien viser 7 cette
grande finale c'est les meilleurs
équipages de chat du monde
n'hésitons pas à le dire
il ya un problème on va essayer de
savoir ce qui s'est passé
et là donc on a pour le deuxième
équipage chênois les épreuves de tir aux
six premières cibles atteintes
[Musique]
deuxième cible à la mitrailleuse et
troisième cible pour l'équipage chinois
ils ont tiré un peu bas
voilà ça y est ils avaient encore des
munitions deux heures ils ont plus
touchant très bien et on voit les
entraîneurs de l'équipage chinois
et voilà l'équipage russe a procédé au
chargement des munitions c'est donc le
deuxième équipage russe sur qui tire
maintenant
oleg orlov qui est donc le tireur poteau
on
il semble que la la cible n'a pas été
atteinte
on va pas se presser en regardant la
deuxième cible s'est déjà relevé alors
passage de relais pour l'équipage de
biélorussie deuxième cible russe
atteinte
oleg orlov qui se prépare à tirer sur la
troisième cible
[Musique]
et cible atteinte
bien on continue
[Musique]
le char de l'équipage russe a reprises
le parcours
[Musique]
l'équipage chinois
achève son premier tour en épreuves de
vitesse
et maintenant c'est la biélorussie qui
effectue aussi son tour de vitesse ses
limites mais la cible a quand même été
touché par l'équipage
dr brion
et on voit la poursuite du mouvement
pour le char heureuse après l'épreuve de
la butte
avec deux tours de pénalité qui ont été
infligés
[Musique]
on vient d'apprendre qu'il n'y aura pas
deux tours de pénalité pour la russie
finalement parce que la cible a été
atteinte à l'extrémité donc voyez ce
chat jaune donc azerbaïdjan qui s'arrête
on ne sait pas pourquoi il ya quelque
chose qui est donc la fédération dossier
a bien touché les trois cibles et
l'équipe 2 rbds l'azerbaïdjan continue
sur l'épreuve de tir mais apparemment
ils ont quelques difficultés
l'équipage s'est arrêtée on ne sait pas
pourquoi et la russie fini son premier
tour on est à 35 2 35 minutes 36
secondes
très bon au score
on voit que ça secoue
[Musique]
et notre pilote sans jeff continue le
mouvement
donc tous ces équipages ont subi un
certain nombre d'épreuves pour être
sélectionné après une instruction une
formation très spécialisés et vous voyez
aujourd'hui l'équipage de la russie ont
travaillé de façon extrêmement concentré
donc
le tout le tournant qui a été le virage
qui a été franchi par l'équipage
biélorusse est là l'épreuve d'obstacles
atlantique
évidemment la responsabilité du pilote
est très importante
voilà deuxième équipage ce sont pour les
quatre équipes ce sont les deux les
deuxième équipage qui interviennent en
ce moment
[Musique]
et voilà les preuves de la butte pour la
biélorussie avec une très bonne vitesse
ici
[Musique]
donc un nombre très limité d'infraction
une pénalité où ont été enregistrés sur
ses équipages
mais on verra que l'étendue des âges est
très varié puisqu'on a des équipages
très jeune et on en a qui sont nettement
plus âgés avec 1 45 47 ans voilà
apparemment les les azerbaïdjanais ou
changer de charron c'est parce qu'ils
encore ce qui s'est passé mais on va
voir
donc là l'équipage de russie ça prépare
se prépare à effectuer le tir le
commandant charles guthrie boczko
watchguard of il va mener le tir au
canon antiaérien
bravo iil a touché l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
il faut encore touché la cible ici à 900
m voilà très bien très bien il a très
bien qu'au geste son tir on est fier de
lui et très très long comment dans le
char très bien
il sert dans la 36e brigade de charme et
voilà le char rouge c'est-à-dire russe
vient de reprendre le parcours
[Musique]
et notre équipage russe va achever son
deuxième tour voilà l'équipage de chine
vient de franchir le fossé antichars là
ils sont arrêtés sur la plateforme de
pénalité ils ont eu une infraction
peut-être sur le parcours d'obstacles
mines et on va regarder ensuite un
rappel et là ils ont apparemment f
ignoré une pénalité et donc ils sont
obligés de recommencer
l'inspection du véhicule
on voit
c'est clair que les équipes à sont tous
très bien préparés ici pour ces épreuves
donc c'est le deuxième tour pour ce
deuxième équipage de chine
[Musique]
donc l'équipe de chine avait un tour
libre à épreuve libre
donc il va passer les obstacles
antichars
[Musique]
c'est à dire un sol parsemé de
d'obstacles
et ensuite il faut passer entre les
points miné
on voit le chat désherbage en sortir du
fossé antichars donc ils ont changé de
véhicule
il arrive sur la plateforme de pénalité
on voit l'équipe de zaba de gens qui a
eu une pénalité
on les voit effectuer leurs pénalités
avec inspection du véhicule
vous voyez qu'il faut sortir vite
éteindre le moteur revenir ra le même
moteur
donc achèvement du deuxième tour pour
l'équipage russe
[Musique]
qui commence le troisième tour
maintenance vous voyez l'équipage russe
donc ça va être ici
ils tirent sûr
la mitrailleuse jumelé au canon
voilà le typage de biélorussie est prêt
à effectuer ses dires il se place face
aux cibles à 1600 mètres
et voilà passage de relais pour
l'azerbaïdjan voilà premier tir pour les
biélorusses
[Musique]
on verra peut-être une rediffusion de se
dire là on voit deuxième cible
voilà c'est fait
[Musique]
le viseur tire un peu bas et on a vu ici
à l'écran le général n'est caché vite
qui commande les la formation militaire
[Musique]
voilà bravo les trois cibles ont été
atteintes atteinte ce qui leur évite
d'avoir des pénalités
vous voyez qu'il ya des supporters face
au mans russes mais aussi biélorusse qui
sont présents ici
[Musique]
et cette année nous avions 16 équipes
qui participaient aux compétitions de
chars et là nous sommes en première les
yeux de deux divisions des équipages de
chars et hier nous avons eu pour la
deuxième division il hier avec le
vietnam le laos et le kazakhstan
et voilà la chine voit la première cible
attentes
[Applaudissements]
et voilà on voit l'équipage russe se
présenter à l'épreuve de tir sur le
stand de tir 9
ici il faut bien calculer et ne pas
gaspiller l'émission voilà une première
cible atteinte
deuxième cible et en même temps les
chinois ont frappé leur cible 3e civ à
cette somme est très bien bravo
sergent-chef ce gameloft bravo
[Musique]
très bon tireur russe bravo ils peuvent
reprendre la route sur le parcours très
bon travail et l'équipe de chine a aussi
frappé la troisième cible
m
[Musique]
et maintenant l'équipage russe va avoir
un tour à parcourir sans sentir
simplement vitesse pure
[Musique]
dans maintenant tous nos espoirs sont
fixé ce samedi dan qui le pilote de char
puce
[Musique]
les équipes ont le droit à un changement
de véhicule pendant les compétitions
mais tous les équipages en cours sur le
même véhicule
nous voyons ce temps exception est
exceptionnellement bon pour ces épreuves
les azerbaïdjanais ont dû changer de
chat et on voit on les voit en ce moment
à l'épreuve de tir il a abattu
l'hélicoptère
et maintenant on doit tirer sur
véhicules armés et
et si la cible n'est pas atteinte alors
il ya des pénalités qui peuvent être un
nouveau tir à 500 mètres de distance ou
la perte de 500 mètres de distance sur
le parcours sur l'ensemble du parcours
en tout cas les azerbaïdjanais sont très
contents d'avoir réussi à se qualifier
en finale
kazakhstan le kazakhstan est aussi très
tout à fait honorable dans ses résultats
mais cette fois ci ils n'ont pas réussi
à se sélectionner en finale
enfin vous voyez que tout le monde est
de bonne humeur ici les équipages très
motivés donc bravo
on verra comment ils se prépareront pour
l'année prochaine
nous attendons avec impatience tous les
participants aux épreuves de l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
et la russie 52 minutes qui avance
on avait une supportrice en costumes
traditionnels soutenir notre équipe est
là notre équipage russe qui franchit les
obstacles routier
et là on voit le chef de char des la
russie qui effectue ces tirs
l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas réussi à frapper
la cible numéro 11
le chef de char biélorusse a réussi à
toucher les deux cibles donc pas de
tours de pénalité jeunes militaires de
l'armée biélorusse 25 ans
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
l'équipage de chine a roulé sur une mine
et là on voit maintenant ils sont suivis
par l'équipage de russie
et il faut que notre équipage aille un
peu plus vite maintenant puisque nous
avons maintenant nous allons maintenant
avoir lu un tour de vitesse pure
[Musique]
donc l'équipe le désert badjan en
premier sur son premier tour
et là vous voyez le chat de biella aussi
répétition du tiens voilà voilà voilà
tire un peu bas mais la cible a été
atteinte et troisième cible aussi c'est
du 125 mm
[Musique]
70 km/heure de vitesse
78 m pour l'équipage russe
l'équipage de chine effectué ces
épreuves de tir sur les cibles numéro 25
et et 11
ouais
c'est d'ailleurs le premier équipage a
attiré sur les cibles numéro 11 avec les
chefs de chars qui doivent tirer
mais apparemment il ya eu un problème au
moment du tir sur la cible numéro 25
bon c'est pas quel problème apparemment
larmes est envoyé on sait pas exactement
quel est le problème technique
ils ont touché la cible numéro 11 mai
pour la sublime aux 25es un problème
voilà voilà
il tire il a dépensé toutes les
munitions et il va devoir faire un tour
de pénalité c'est l'équipage de chimie
ils ont décidé pas perdre de temps donc
un tour de pénalité
l'équipage de chine a décidé de procéder
à un changement de véhicule ça veut dire
qu'ils avaient donc effectivement un
problème technique
et voilà deuxième passage de relais pour
l'équipe russe
[Applaudissements]
voilà cet équipage qui a très bien joué
qui est du district militaire est
remplacé par un nouvel équipage
[Applaudissements]
leonid petrov aux commandes en charge du
district militaire sud ou entraînée par
le colonel rodtchenko
[Applaudissements]
et le duel se poursuit
sous les grands applaudissements des
applaudissements nourris
on voit notre troisième équipage russe
partir sur le parcours
donc marseille le trafic neuf chefs de
chats tous a dit naji châle des tireurs
pointer avec mango les pilotes
avant de commencer cette émission nous
avons peu parlé un petit peu avec les
équipages
évidemment ils ont tous le trac c'est
normal mais en même temps on voit une
dent leurs yeux une certaine certitude
une résolution à se battre de très bons
gars bien formés bien instruits
[Musique]
voilà un deuxième chara était préparé
pour l'équipe chinoise
voilà celui ci est retiré du jeu et donc
l'équipage de chine va devoir faire
effectuer deux tours de pénalité pour ne
pas avoir frappé atteint la cible
et voilà l'équipage
vous vous avez un reflet l'équipage de
l'azerbaïdjan qui effectivement méritait
une pénalité
et donc là on voit l'équipage de
biélorussie effectuer ces tirs à la
mitrailleuse
[Applaudissements]
deuxième cible touchée est-ce qu'ils ont
encore assez de munitions pour la
troisième cible c'est bon bravo
ils sont réussis les trois cibles ont
été atteints dhr atteinte
donc le deuxième équipage de bella aussi
peut achever son tour donc épreuve de
tirs à la mitrailleuse pour la
l'azerbaïdjan
et c'est le soldat durant gaza daf qui
effectue les tirs il attire un peu un
peu on est un peu bas au dessus de la
cible
[Musique]
il risque d'avoir un manque de munitions
voilà les chinois effectue le passage de
relais et voilà il touche la main de
l'autre équipage
ils reviennent
et voilà ce sont eux qui se sera ce
nouvel engin qui effectuera la suite
et voilà deuxièmes chars chinois sur le
parcours d'épreuves
deuxième cible touchée pas là
l'azerbaïdjan
chers amis revenons au troisième
équipage russe qui est se prépare à
effectuer les tirs ils ont déjà touché
la première cible à 1600 mètres et pour
la cible numéro 9 pour l'azerbaïdjan par
aman la deuxième cible n'a pas été
touché en quoi est-ce qu'ils vont
vraiment avoir un tour de pénalité
pourtant il avait bien commencé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc séance de tir
pour l'équipage russe
bon sang c'est difficile de dire mais il
est possible que la cible était touchée
où on ne sait pas deuxième cible
on retient sa respiration à 1700 mètres
[Musique]
et troisième celle 1600 mètres le tireur
russe ce troisième équipage se prépare à
tirer
[Applaudissements]
il faut vraiment la touche cette cible
l'équipage de l'identifier
[Applaudissements]
l'équipage de russie envisage peut-être
une pénalité
[Musique]
il ya longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu
autant de tension sur une finale bois
troisième équipage de biélorussie et
c'est l'équipage le plus ancien à
l'exception du congo richard qui lui est
tout jeune et vient sortie d'école pas
mal d'eau dick le tira c'est le sergent
denis smith and gold qui a déjà
participé plusieurs fois et les télés
bolton
[Musique]
10 47 ans et qui a déjà participé au
biathlon de chat voyez l'équipe de chine
en train de tirs sur le stand de tir
numéro 9
[Musique]
dans les tirs à la mitrailleuse de 7,62
la cible est touché
[Musique]
donc le ca
de remplacement je vous le rappelle qui
donc reprend le parcours
donc l'équipage de chine a dû faire un
tour de pénalité pour le remplacement de
leur véhicule et on voit le charvier
d'azerbaïjan s'approcher
hélas le char russe
[Musique]
et voilà malheureusement l'équipage
russe a eu un problème apparemment
technique pour le mot niveau de la
tourelle qui apparemment est survenu
maintenant au troisième tour elle a 3 au
troisième équipage il faudra peut-être
changer de chat donc dragon prochain
donc il faut pas être trop triste mais
il faut tenir
et donc on a eu quelques quelques
palpitations à presser
preuve ici à alabina aux
applaudissements sont nécessaires
on voit les là l'équipe d abattre gens
qui fini voilà attention donc on voit
ralentissement juste avant cet obstacle
et notre équipage à h 20 tours et
maintenant ils vont effectuer un tir au
canon antiaérien sur des cibles
représentant d'hélicoptères et en
véhicules harnais on voit une très bonne
vitesse 55 60 kilomètres heure le
drapeau blanc a été levée au moment du
passage de terrain miné
donc il n'y a pas eu d'infraction
encore un passage escarpé pas facile à
franchir missiles
[Musique]
marcel hafiz off qui est le pilote et de
ce chat
donc équipage troisième équipage chinois
qui achève son premier tour et
maintenant pour les chinois savent être
le tour de vitesse pure sentir
[Musique]
il faut savoir que les équipages cherche
aussi à salir le moins possible nos
objectifs de viser pour faciliter
justement les procédures de visée lors
des tirs là l'équipage russe décembre
remonte pour charger les munitions
et voilà
marcel graf is off se prépare à tirer
il arme sa mitrailleuse
[Musique]
attention les cibles sont prêtes
troisième équipage russe tir au canon
antiaérien bravo touchés
tout près
un peu bas
ils économisent les munitions de kiltir
au tour parcours ou en petites rafales
est-ce qu'il a encore des munitions de
réserve
donc toutes les tribunes ne sont dans le
silence en sont ils encore des munitions
bravo il a réussi marcel hafiz of très
bien il nous a fait avoir des
palpitations
mais voilà bravo c'est reparti le char
reprend son parcours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut-être un problème technique et
donc apparemment isolés entre le mot
niveau de la tourelle et on ne s'arrête
pas on continue nous allons avoir un
changement de véhicule et donc tu un
tour de pénalité en plus
regarderez l'azerbaïdjan
en 3e du tour
et c'est encore le deuxième équipage
donc ce char de couleur jaune
[Musique]
donc encore quelques secondes avant le
franchissement de la ligne d'arrivée
pour l'azerbaïdjan et c'est encore le
deuxième et petit col
et on regarde les temps pour l'instant
la chine est actuellement en première
position
le saut dans le sang sans pénalité
regardez notre magnifique char
[Musique]
c'est en 2013 que les premiers biathlon
de chars avaient été lancés à
l'initiative des ministres de la défense
de la fédération de russie le général
shogo à l'époque il ne veut que quatre
pays participants mais la popularité de
ce coucou on n'a cessé de croître et
d'autres pays se sont intéressés à cette
épreuve est aujourd'hui cette
compétition dès 2015
il a été le bien toujours eu ça a été un
petit peu le père de toutes les épreuves
similaires dans le monde donc on a cette
année la sixième édition
j'espère que les organisateurs des
autres biathlon de nous en vaudront
voudront pas mais nous avons pour
l'instant la primauté et regardez ce
cette adrénaline voilà changement de
chars
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà ils sont prêts à reprendre le
mouvement après ce changement de chars
[Musique]
pour lui
donc s'ils ont deux côtés pour la
biélorussie regardez ils cherchent la
cible normalement c'est pas bon donc il
s'agit ici de retrouver la bonne
position en direction de la cible
premier tir première cible atteinte pour
la biélorussie
deuxième cible se présente
[Musique]
deuxième cible touché juste sur le côté
et troisième cible
et en même temps les chinois qui tirent
au canon antiaérien les biélorusses ont
touché les trois cibles
bravo première cible atteinte pour
l'équipage chinois
[Musique]
et deuxième ses notes
notre équipe
je mets en position pour tirer sur le
stand de justice numéro 9 dans ghana
descharles daïeff qui va tirer après
l'épreuve qui a rencontré un problème
technique tout à l'heure donc les cibles
sont en position sur le chantier
le colonel rodtchenko donne des
instructions
c'est lui l'entraîneur des équipages
on va aussi une cible pour le deuxième
équipage d'azerbaïjan voilà premières
cibles touchées pour l'équipage russe
sur le stand de tir numéro 9
voilà deuxièmes ciblées et l'azerbaïdjan
aussi il reste une cible pour l'équipage
russe a un peu bas
la tribune cris guénard c'est à dire
c'est le nom du tireur russe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour les aires marines de tir un peu
trop élevé
et voilà troisièmes cibles touchées y en
a des centaines à tirer correctement
très bien équipage doji donc toutes les
épreuves de tir du troisième équipage de
chars accompli
et les azerbaïdjanais se voit infliger
des tours de pénalité deux tours de
pénalité pour leur badge ans pour les
cibles n'ont touché sur le stand de
terni mien numéro 12
l'équipage de russie se réhabiliter
après
le tir raté due à une un problème
technique
[Musique]
voilà 500 m de pénalité
des représentants de leurs familles sont
là sur les tribunes et soutiennent les
membres de l'équipage
[Musique]
le troisième équipage pour la russie il
ne reste pas grand chose à faire et il
va avoir trois obstacles ici le pilote
sert à l'aise mouled ali boulad alief
donc la butte
[Musique]
et on voit le chat d'intervalle gens qui
vient de franchir
[Musique]
l'épreuve d'obstacles aquatique et là
attention les obstacles pour l'instant
nous n'avons eu aucune pénalité sur ces
obstacles
vous voyez les arbitres à côté sur le
fossé antichars
aucune pénalité 3e équipe équipages pour
la biélorussie sur le tir au canon
antiaérien
le jeune lieutenant pas mélodique
[Applaudissements]
donc les cibles en place
[Musique]
d'autres équipes de chine pour l'instant
se rapproche du point de chargement des
munitions et la biélorussie n'a pas
atteint ils ont deux tours de pénalité
pour ne pas avoir touché les cibles
l'azerbaïdjan continue revient
maintenant avec eux passage de relais
il détaille le moteur et changement
d'équipage
voilà où on est pour l'instant
bravo pour ce magnifique travail
le troisième équipage s'installe dans le
chat d'azerbaïdjan voici amis d'aliev
saddam à la ghibli et samir iskander
voilà donc la chine sur le tir
[Musique]
voilà on voit les épreuves de tir pour
l'équipage chinois à 1700 mètres
doko au quatrième tour en ce moment les
équipages de chine et de russie
[Musique]
deuxième cible chinoise atteinte
et on voit
on voit aujourd'hui maintenant le char
russe en première position
ils en sont simplement autour de vitesse
pure
sans ce sens objectif de tirs sans
épreuve de tir
troisième cible pour
l'équipage chinois cibles touchées
bravo à l'équipage chinois
[Musique]
on voit l'équipage chinois il vient de
passer le l'épreuve de gay voilà on a
ici une retransmission des tirs de
l'équipage chinois et regarder les
supporteurs chinois très content
malgré leur masse on les voit sourire
[Musique]
nous précisons que pour la chine comme
pour la russie l'équipe est complètement
renouvelée chaque année
regardez la butte
très très long passage de la ddt de la
butte
et voilà l'un troisième équipage russe
achève ses tours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà ils ont franchi la ligne
d'arrivée
bravo 1h28 53 secondes
bravo à notre équipe russe le ministre
de la russie le général choïgou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ainsi que le chef d'état-major
des troupes terrestres le général ça le
kof
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et regardez les équipes chinoises qui
vient d'arriver 36 secondes de
différence
vous voyez très bonne formation très
bonne préparation mais ce sont les
russes qui remporte la victoire bravo
pour eux et voilà nous avons confirmé
que les troupes terrestres de l'armée
russe sont en première position
[Musique]
bravo les gars le troisième équipage de
l'équipe russe
le tenant marcel graf is of ghana du
soldat f et pilotes
khalil voldo ghallef l'équipe de russie
champion de biathlon de chars de melgven
grande victoire à l'occasion en cette
année où nous fêtons le 75e anniversaire
de la victoire sur le nazisme
bravo les amis notre équipe est
championne
notre équipe va être saluée
maintenant après ce tour d'honneur
donc c'est vraiment cette année un
record pour les biathlètes de chat tout
le monde applaudit maintenant les
chinois qui ont été très bons l'équipe
de chine était aussi très très bien
préparés et ils n'ont que 36 secondes de
retard sur l'équipe russe
[Musique]
nous revenons sur le parcours des
épreuves avec les azerbaïdjanais qui
effectue le tir au canon antiaérien sur
les cibles
l'équipage bill russe doit encore
effectuer une séance de tir sur le stand
de tir numéro 9
encore une fois bravo aux équipages
russes très bien soutenu par de très
nombreux supporters
et voilà à allah benno nos jeunes
équipages de chats participantes de
biathlon de faim fatigués ils ont été à
5 100 % de leurs capacités
bravo à tous et attention revient sur le
stand de tir pour l'équipage de
biélorussie
4e tour tirs à la mitrailleuse au
bravo une cible atteinte
et l'année dernière l'équipe de
biélorussie avait achevé son la
compétition à 1h41 un peu bas et voilà
bravo troisième cible atteinte très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voyez ici les supporters de l'équipe
biélorusse
voilà pour l'instant sept premiers tours
pour le troisième équipage l'azerbaïdjan
vous voyez l'équipage de l'azerbaïdjan
donc ce char et dispose d'une manoeuvre
habilité renforcée il a été
mis en disposition à disposition dans
les unités en 2019
et cette année nous fêtons le 100e
anniversaire de la construction de chat
en russie de l'époque soviétique donc ça
avait commencé et nous regardent au
voyons aujourd'hui les capacités de
combat et de tir tout à fait
exceptionnelle de ses chats et donc le
forum a remis 20 2020 cette année a
permis de comparer les équipements les
capacités techniques etc
on a vu les larmes de joie d'émotion du
de l'entraîneur de chinois
[Applaudissements]
cher participants de cette compétition
voilà à vous de choisir votre place dans
les deux qui restent donc la russie
remporté
la première place la chine la deuxième
et on voit les biélorusses s'avancer
pour avoir remporté la troisième place
sur chars t-72 b3 et l'azerbaïdjan
achève son deuxième tour
donc c'est même si l'azerbaïdjan n'est
qu'à la quatrième place c'est quand même
tout à fait honorable puisque il s'agit
aujourd'hui de la finale de ce biathlon
de chars
donc il ya tout un tas de méthodes
d'entraînement qui sont utilisés ici qui
sont perfectionnés chaque année et les
armées de russie de biélorussie
d'azerbaïjan procès d'un échange
permanent d'expérience et voilà la
troisième place est remportée par la
biélorussie avec 8 minutes 55 de retard
par rapport au vainqueur russe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici à la meinau la patrie la terre
natale du premier
[Musique]
il ya trop de charges donc beaucoup
d'adrénaline
aujourd'hui
ça fait
la huitième année que nous organisons
cette
compétition alors le char azerbaïdjanais
sur le stand de tir
pour l'instant le tir se déroule très
bien première cible deuxième cible
touchée donc tirs à la mitrailleuse et
troisième cible atteinte bravo
sans pénalité le chat reprend le
parcours
on voit que l'azerbaïdjan a sérieusement
amélioré ses résultats au cours des
dernières années
pour la quatrième année consécutive et
on voit qu'ici la capacité de tir
prévaut sur la vitesse donc une heure
quarante aujourd'hui déjà de compétition
[Musique]
qui passe d' azerbaïdjan qui est donc en
dernière position
ici en finale à 60 kilomètres/heure en
ce moment
[Musique]
avec 36 secondes de retard sur la
première équipe c'était à l'équipe russe
l'équipe chinoise a terminé en deuxième
position
il faut dire que l'atmosphère y est
particulièrement chaleureuse et amicale
à ce bien que l'on entre les équipages
des différents pays et c'est surtout
l'occasion pour les équipages de
procéder à un échange d'expériences
le passage du gué
sont des jeux de l'amitié de jeu de la
bonne humeur l'équipage d'un badge ans
achève son deuxième tour et de troisième
sera donc un tour de vitesse pure
[Musique]
bref il faut travailler s'entraîner
régulièrement pour maintenir toujours un
très bon niveau
et l'équipage désherbage en étant est en
finale et ça c'est déjà un très très bon
résultat
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui à 19 heures dans le parc
patriotes et son centre d'exposition il
y aura la cérémonie de clôture des
sixièmes jeux militaires internationaux
à l'occasion du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire sur le nazisme
pour la deuxième année consécutive les
équipes se divise en deux divisions
[Musique]
et donc cette année nous avons la
première participation de quatre équipes
au cetir phrasé congo et
et donc il devrait y avoir chaque année
de nouvelles équipes
et l'équipage de ce type du sud a
remporté la troisième position en
résultat individuel donc l'intérêt pour
ces épreuves mais c'est ne cesse
d'augmenter et cela fait partie de la
coopération internationale sur le plan
militaire
c'est aussi un signe de l'amitié entre
nos peuples
pourvu que cette atmosphère se
maintiennent et l'équipage batam adjoint
est ici à son troisième tour
tous les espoirs se fondent sur les
capacités de sergent iskanderov qui est
le conducteur du char
sachez que vous avez toujours la
possibilité de venir directement ici sur
les tribunes pour assister à cette
compétition passionnante
[Applaudissements]
il ya aussi dans le parc patriotes des
appareils d'entraînement vous pouvez
faire de la simulation de surcharge
[Applaudissements]
et nous serons toujours heureux
d'accueillir les visiteurs dans ce parc
d'autre part cette année sur décision du
général choïgou ministre de la défense
il a eu en même temps un forum technique
militaire et les militaires et la
pratique a montré que c'était une
excellente
cela permet de voir à quel point les
participants sont motivés et cette
pratique devrait se maintenir pour les
années à venir
durant toute la semaine
indépendamment des jeux militaires sous
l'autorité du général salou cov
commandant des troupes terrestres de la
fédération de russie ont eu lieu un
certain nombre de deux présentations
techniques sur ce terrain d'exercice et
on voit les quais par d'intervalle gens
qui pour son quatrième tour donc
s'arrête et se prépare à effectuer le
dernier tir en procédant au chargement
des munitions nous poursuivons la
diffusion de ce biathlon de chat
regardez le chargement on voit qu'ils
sont fatigués les pauvres mais ils
poursuivent la lutte encore quelques
secondes de travail ils doivent battre
leur propre record qui est le record de
leurs propres armes et donc c'est clair
qu'ils vont bien se préparer pour
l'année prochaine pour leur
participation suivante
mais là ils ont atteint très bon niveau
auquel il faut se maintenir
évidemment pour que l'année prochaine et
une puce avoir d'excellents résultats et
peut-être être pas remis
et trois meilleurs
donc c'est un kazakhstan n'a pas réussi
à se sélectionner en finale mais en tout
cas on garde mémoire des prestations du
kazakhstan les années précédentes
notamment l'année dernière où ils ont
été vraiment très très bon donc
première cible à 1600 mètres la cible
est prête
1h49
les supporters azerbaïdjanais sont
certainement très tendu il faut que
l'équipage touche les cibles
donc ils tirent à l'obus de 125 mm ici
l'équivalent du celui qui tire un
penalty dans un match de foot
ici c'est le tireur viseur et la
distance sur laquelle l'équipage doit
effectuer ces tirs et 2 400 mètres
bravo premier première cible le travail
ne s'arrête pas il ya encore deux cibles
à abattre est encore un demi tour et
c'est la ligne d'arrivée alors 1700
mètres ici
êtes à côté les supporteurs vont être
certainement déçu mais il ya encore une
cible à abattre
bravo cibles touchées
donc deux cibles sur les trois dont été
touché regardez le replay
deuxième cible l'obus appartient peu à
gauche
et oui et son toucher juste le bas de la
cible donc un tour de pénalité
encore trois obstacles pour ce char pour
achever la compétition
[Musique]
nous sommes ici à côté de deux colonels
rechante aux entraîneurs de l'équipe
russe
pourquoi nous avons dû remplacer
procéder à un remplacement de chars mais
enfin bon
en tout cas nous avons réussi à
remporter cette compétition
[Musique]
le char se rapproche de la ligne
d'arrivée merci aux entraîneurs des
différentes équipes de biélorussie des
herbes adjoint de chine est bien entendu
de russie et donc merci d'avoir organisé
ce via ton de chars qui est apprécié de
tout le peuple en russie et cette finale
on ne l'oubliera pas elle était vraiment
exceptionnel
c'était une des finales les plus
impressionnantes ans et 8 ans
d'existence du biathlon de chat et voilà
le chat azerbaïdjanais est sur la ligne
d'arrivée
la compétition est terminée pour
aujourd'hui
on va regarder encore les meilleurs
moments de cette compétition même s'il
n'était pas toujours très agréables
vous avez ici le tableau des résultats
d' et en équipage par équipage et pays
par pays
[Musique]
donc 1h28 53 secondes pour la russie qui
est championne
voilà
on revoit les meilleurs moments de cette
compétition d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on commence pas la ligne 4 c'est-à-dire
l'azerbaïdjan
[Musique]
tout cela signifie que l'azerbaïdjan est
quand même une des meilleures armées sur
cette compétition puisqu'ils ont réussi
à se qualifier en finale
[Musique]
troisième ligne c'est la biélorussie
avec une équipe formidable
on peut dire beaucoup de choses de cette
très bonne équipe
et chaque année l'équipe de biélorussie
nous réjouit ils sont toujours très sûrs
d'eux est très motivé et en même temps
bien calme bien sûr 1
[Musique]
l'année dernière l'équipe de biélorussie
avait été en deuxième position cette
année seulement la troisième mais en
tout cas quand même sur le piédestal
donc médaille de bronze pour l'équipe de
biélorussie
[Musique]
et là vous avez sur votre écran une très
bonne équipe qui constitue toujours un
défi c'est l'équipe 2 2 la chine avec un
renouvellement à 100% de l'équipe
nationale
[Musique]
ils ont donné un niveau très élevé au
niveau un intérêt individuel comme haut
niveau par équipes
[Musique]
et il ya même un équipage chinois qui a
été le plus rapide
est ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui
le niveau de pression a été élevé
tant pour les équipes des entraîneurs
que pour les supporters qui étaient dans
les tribunes
et voilà on peut souffler nous sommes en
tête new lows donc médaille d'argent
pour la chaîne
[Musique]
et surtout
c'est l'équipe de la fédération de
russie en première place équipe aussi
renouvelée à 100% avec trois équipages
titulaire et un équipage de réserve
[Musique]
les équipages ont touché toutes les
cibles et même les problèmes qu'ils ont
eue au troisième tour problème technique
une panne qui a nécessité donc un
d'imposer un remplacement de chars
[Musique]
deux avions beaucoup misé sur l'équipe
russe et on voit le résultat
là le niveau de compétence de nos chefs
de charles de nos tireurs et de nos
pilotes ont réussi à assurer cette
victoire avec une grande motivation
[Musique]
et voilà l'équipe de russes et
championne de ce biasion de chars bravo
à l'équipe d'entraîneurs bravo à tous
nos compétiteurs
et merci aux commandants des troupes
terrestres et au ministre de la défense
[Musique]
et voilà vous voyez les résultats sur
votre écran
[Musique]
m